active learning means you participate
collaborate with others and apply
concepts to the real world
it requires hard mental effort but leads
to better retention
and an understanding of the material
that can be transferred to other
situations
to understand why active learning works
so well it helps to know
that when our brain decides what to
remember it asks itself
two fundamental questions can i
understand
and do i need to know
when you ask can i understand your brain
always puts the new information on the
foundation of existing knowledge
if the foundation is missing the brain
has no idea what to do with it
and as a result it throws it away
in other words your brain needs to build
foundational neuron connections for new
information to attach to
which is both why active learning is
more mental work but also essential for
learning
when we ask ourselves do i need to know
our brain
separates between the material it finds
worth to remember
and the one it can forget if it's
unlikely that new information will ever
be used again
the brain is smart enough to throw it
away if your brain finds that the
information is needed again
say it could increase your social status
the brain will store it
in long-term memory to stay there and be
easily recalled
you just have to periodically use or
think of it
to understand how active learning is
applied in classrooms
let's look at the teachings of professor
carl wyman
a nobel prize winning physicist and a
leading proponent of the method
there are four steps to it
step one prior to class the students
read up on the fundamentals of a lesson
so they get an idea of the terms and
basic phenomena
in class professor wyman starts with a
brief introduction
and then gives questions to solve he
will have students use clickers
a little device on which students can
answer multiple choice questions
alternatively or for more complex
problems worksheets can be handed out
step 2 wyman projects a problem and
asks all the students to select one of
three possible answers using their
clicker
this has two benefits first the teacher
gets an idea of how many of his students
already understand the topic
and second the students are now focused
on the question
they want to know if they are right it
is important though that the question is
both challenging and interesting
all this takes less than five minutes
step three without telling the students
how they voted
and following eric mouser's peer
instruction method which involves
questions
peer discussions votes and group
discussions the students then discuss
the question
and their answers with one or two
classmates ideally with someone who
disagrees with their own opinion
during the discussion the students have
to come up with a reason for their
answer and why the others may be wrong
meanwhile the instructor is circling
around listening in to gauge student
thinking and answering brief questions
then there will be a second clicker vote
and only now the results will be shown
typically the second vote will be much
better than the first as students learn
a great deal from their discussions
an ideal question will have about a
third correct on the first vote and 85
percent correct on the second
all this takes around seven minutes
step four now the professor leads a
follow-up discussion with all the
students to provide feedback
exploring the different reasoning which
one is correct and importantly
which is incorrect and why
only at the very end professor wyman
will explain the correct solution and
answer follow-up questions
ascertaining the student's understanding
from the questions they ask
he decides if it is time to move on all
of which takes around
10 minutes there are three reasons why
active learning works so well
first the students are actively working
on interesting problems
and as they all voted for an answer
right at the beginning
they have a stake in the outcome that
means their brains decide that the
information covered is important to be
remembered
and are hence more receptive for
learning
second by solving problems alone and in
groups they dive deeply into the
material
explaining to appear engages novel
mental processes
as a result they construct new synaptic
pathways inside their brains
third the explanation from the teacher
comes only once the students already
formed their own thoughts about the
concept
at this point the explanation makes more
sense as the brain can connect the new
information
to all the thought it had just built the
correct answers have a solid foundation
a large body of research has shown big
differences in the outcomes between
passive
and active learning in one carefully
executed experiment
physics instructors taught their course
in two ways some classes were taught in
a conventional style
and others using active learning even
though the teachers were the same and
the students were similar
on average the active learners doubled
their understanding when they were
tested at the end of the course
[Music]
other experiments have shown that
long-term retention is higher as well
students that take conventional lecture
that is followed by a test forget around
ninety percent of the material within
six months
in an active learning environment
students can retain more than seventy
percent of what they have learned
two years later
sometimes teachers show a problem and
then demonstrate to the class how to
solve it
they believe that they can just transfer
their own thinking into the student's
head through an explanation
unfortunately for new ideas a brain
doesn't work that way
unless the brain actively constructs
those ideas within
it is as if the material was never heard
how about you have you ever learned in
an active learning environment
and if so how does it compare to
learning the conventional way
[Music]
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts
even one dollar can make a difference